this pandemic has highlighted how
essential and heroic our frontline
workers really are
and we can't thank them enough but we
wanted to do something special
for one of them she's a single mom which
is already a full-time job and
as well she is a nurse she's been
selflessly braving it to work every
single day
to be there for her patients please meet
nurse kate
hi thanks for joining us i wanted you to
meet my boss too to tell
tell us both a little bit about your
story that's okay
okay cool i think they're there
oh here she is hi kate how are you
oh my gosh i'm so good
thank you for talking with me so my
pleasure
i am really excited
you're excited i am thrilled
well i'm so happy to meet a nurse who
takes care of people
and a mom to a 21 year old son
and you're living in your first big
house that you own and you so deserve it
thank you how does it feel to have this
gorgeous home that you
own it is amazing um
i just feel that you know
you have children i always put my son
first and he's 21 now
and now i'm like let's do me i just feel
very accomplished and excited
and it's a really great feeling
i feel like all the hard work and all
the struggles i've had throughout the
years
finally like paid off and you know
getting somewhere that i wanted to be
i commend you for all of the sacrifices
and everything that you did
and i want to celebrate where you're at
right now thank you
kate how do you feel about if
i um help you design your living room
i would be so excited it's like a dream
come true
before i get started also really want to
ask you a quick couple questions because
i want to be your partner in this
okay is there anything that you
absolutely hate
hmm that's a good question there's
really like nothing that i'm opposed
to got it what is your favorite color
um my favorite color i like blues great
blues great greens are good too i love
greens would you ever dare to go dark
i would definitely go dark i do have two
windows in the living room the front one
is
um quite large is there a time in design
that you love or you're just like yeah i
could never rock that style
well i have to be honest if you're
styling it i think i'd be able to rock
anything
i'm so glad do you have you been
watching like what we do on the show
or have you seen the flower home
in our home yes this designs are so
adorable and great
and like i wouldn't even know how to mix
and match but i love them all
i feel honored to do this with you and
at this moment and time and this
celebratory chapter
thank you for having me to your party
thank you
alright kate here we go let's do this
after surprising kate the team and i
went to
work compiling the right colors
furniture
accessory and style to give her a living
space where she can
kick her feet up and relax after her
long important days